but dude yesterday we were hanging out
with with
um
um [__] dietrichs and he was
like ashamed of his acting I'm like
you're way better than [__] Clan Van
Damme
I don't even know dietrichs can do the
splits and that movie where he's acting
got a six percent so yeah
all right this is for the OG's out there
all right in Rotten Tomatoes news
submitted by rhianime submitted by me oh
because I told you about it oh some
users submitted it by Ryan anime and
they and this is about how Rotten
Tomatoes scores have been manipulated
they [__] dude by a PR firm they're
[__] and they're paying critics for
reviews is this recent or has it always
been this way well so the story is
breaking recently right this week I
never trusted because I always thought
it was rig for some reason when I saw
that movie Equalizer three get like 90
of Rotten Tomatoes I was like it's not
that good how the [__] did this movie
get 90 dude 90 because some of them is
it not the reviews I was like why that
made no more it just didn't make any
sense and it never matched the public
sentiment so I was like something's
going on here it doesn't make and I
stopped [__] looking at Rotten
Tomatoes This was like years ago but it
was the same reason as you because they
would have the audience score be
different than the review score yeah and
then they're always going to be
different but like sometimes it's like
40 50 points different right and it's so
at that point I thought who are these
[__] gatekeeping snobs that I think
they know it film but they don't know
film or they're just so Niche that they
trash everything else that they don't
like and they only like a little style
of you know so I'm like they're not real
like good critics and maybe maybe I
don't like their tastes but now this
makes way more sense so what was
happening this is this is a PR firm
who's basically paying people
to give reviews just paying randos
basically to like go hey go establish
your account on Rotten Tomatoes and then
give us a good review and then we'll pay
you I'll do that and so the pr firm it's
not Rotten Tomato saying hey
and we'll give you some good good
reviews you pay us right it's this PR
firm so they're they're basically
exploiting the Rotten Tomatoes layout
yeah and using it to actually help make
money for
um movies that otherwise wouldn't really
make that much that's why we need Roger
and Ebert dude we need those guys back
didn't they give two thumbs down to hook
damn
dude Cisco and Ebert it's a toffee but I
get it though it's also one of those
things where sometimes from a critics
point of view a movie like sucks and
then it becomes a cultural phenomenon
later oh yeah like blood sport
I don't know what the Grant's not
universally known to be that but also
too I think that's just us I feel like
when movies you really do have to go in
watching it for what the movie's
supposed to be and that's the hard part
that's the hard part right it's like
it's like when I go watch [__] what's
a movie example like like for instance
Barbie
I watched I went to that movie thinking
all right it's gonna be a fun time at
the movie it's not gonna be anything
[__] that serious it's not gonna be
that big of a deal but I remember I had
a very
fun viewing experience but my wife she
went in with a complete different
mindset well she just she thought she's
a fashion girl so she was like I was
expecting all these outfits and blah
blah blah blah there weren't enough
outfits she didn't think there was there
was too many for me hey dude my wife
said there wasn't enough outfits okay
not enough outfits I was overwhelmed
yeah yeah and I was like and she was
like yeah it was cool like that and I
was like okay but I I left I was like
that was so funny I had such a fun time
I remember last time I had that much fun
in a movie in a while me too it was my
favorite movie of the year so far yeah
honestly when does the review of the
movie start does it start with like
trailer one then because the trailer
already starts to prep you of how you
should watch the movie I think the
problem is sometimes the trailer throws
it one way yeah and then you go watch
the movie and then so you try to go in
with that bias that you feel like the
trailer trailer told you to have I say
no trailers dude yeah no trailers you
want to go watch it or not whoa I don't
know if you're I think you just have to
go on the subject matter of the movie
right I think trailers like for one
example where did it to us was like we
were so excited to watch forgotten like
me and Quest you ever seen that movie
forgotten no so in the trailer it's like
this lady wakes up basically and she's I
guess her life she had like a kid and
then that used to play with the
neighbors kid and then she wakes up she
doesn't have a kid the neighbor doesn't
have a kid and the neighbor's like what
are you talking about and there's no
pictures of kids in any of their houses
yeah she's [__] nuts and then she's
like what the [__] did I did I just
imagine my life and then at one point in
the movie like she uh or the trailer
they [__] rip the wallpaper and the
kid wallpaper's still there and it makes
you go what the [__] yeah and you just
want to know what happened and then you
watch the movie and you're like oh the
answer is aliens that [__] sucks yeah
yeah yeah yeah see that's why you gotta
go no trailer I think that's why it
could work against you and like you
didn't want that but doesn't that make
you want to watch the movies I think it
does but then like I think people's own
expectations when they go watch a movie
it'll ruin it for him I think at least
for me but that's also the job objective
of the person making trailers that's not
usually the guy who made the movie the
guy who made the trailer is just getting
people in the [__] getting you
interested getting that hook of like oh
what the [__] and they definitely
misrepresent what films are a lot of the
time they'll even even remember we've
talked about this like um they'll use
scenes that are completely cut from the
trailer yeah but they won't anymore they
don't need anymore but they're they were
doing that for a long time and then you
go to the movie you don't even see that
whole scene they're just trying to trick
you into the theater but that lawsuit
like totally cut that out of the biz
didn't it yeah
so basically this this PR form is called
bunker 15. they were manipulating the
rotten uh Tomato score of a project by
paying critics for positive reviews and
burying the negative ones the project in
question is a 2018 movie called Ophelia
which nobody literally ever heard of a
female fronted adaptation of Hamlet
starring Daisy Ridley does that sound
great or what dude no one is gonna watch
that Daisy Ridley's a Star Wars girl
yeah Ophelia is that like a like a
Shakespeare yeah that sounds like a big
project but the trailer was good because
it had like a bunch of Shakespeare
scenes with ba with the bar
oh that's tight yeah yeah and Hans
Zimmer [__] scoring it wow no one's
watching that bro but the ball with the
ballpark got me
so it was not a good movie people didn't
like it uh early press greetings uh said
that they just got 46 in in like rotten
within 13 reviews seven of which were
negative and then bunker 15 the pr firm
got to work quote unquote started taking
on obscure often self-published critics
who are still part of the Rotten
Tomatoes attract reviewers so people who
maybe weren't doing that much which is
the weird thing that like they have the
same value as the LA Times or like as
someone that puts their rep out
constantly so hey resuscitate your
account you're not doing that much hey
come on back you're already on here why
don't you give us a positive review and
we'll pay you for it and that's what
they were doing smart move yep and they
were able to pay them 50 dollars or more
per positive review and wow the all of a
sudden they started to get more positive
um you know feedback the score goes up
to 62 percent and a month later IFC film
bought distribution rights for its U.S
release well good for them that's the
accessory the biggest good for them so
now IFC films got ripped off essentially
knowing that using this model they can
sell the movie they obviously you're
using like algorithms and stuff to be
like hey if that's this amount of
percents we can definitely track it in
through these markets and get enough
eyeballs they they do do that even
without the Rotten Tomatoes Amazon yeah
some movies they'll have like however
many theater release they know if they
could pack however many tickets then
they'll open up the next batch of
theater releases so some people just
straight up buy out the whole theater
and there's no one in there just so they
can open up okay it's cool we have these
15 territories now these 25 territories
also Now open up so it's not like I
guess not unique to them yeah and all I
gotta say is great job bunker 15. yeah I
mean they did hack the system yeah you
you had a job you completed it got the
[__] movie distributed
but the backlash is worse for the movie
I feel like think so yeah because now
you know like we've always said Rotten
Tomatoes probably had something uh weird
about something but it's also that that
by the way that site was created and
still owned by like an Asian dude so
that's cool when I saw a Wizard of Oz
have a hundred percent I was like man
[__] that classic film but you mean the
original yeah why is that bad I don't
know I think one time I was searching I
was like what has a hundred percent and
it said Wizard of Oz and I was like we
don't got the same taste you think
wizard balls is whack I mean that's a
Zeitgeist it's not as good as blood more
another hundred ah dude see it's a
blizzard of Oz if Bloodsport was 100 I'm
like dude it's a classic I trust your
taste but I don't really quite trust
their taste if it's it's structurally
it's structurally really good too but
this is the first time that Rotten
Tomatoes actually did something about it
oh really yeah that's why I think it's
bad for the film yeah so
um Rotten Tomatoes delisted a bunch of
the firm's movies oh like bunker 15 from
the site and they said look we take
Integrity of our scores very seriously
we don't tolerate any attempts to
manipulate them or gain them we have a
dedicated team who monitors our
platforms regularly and thoroughly
investigates and resolves any suspicious
activity
um but yeah this Scandal aside what
we're talking about what kind of smells
like they did an entire report about
this that goes into in detail about
issues Rotten Tomatoes in their system
which has been slammed by filmmakers all
over the years including Scorsese he's
like hey this destroyed the art of
individual experts thoughts and opinions
and created a big Collective where we
all just review a big a number instead
of individual submission finding out why
yeah someone dissecting it you used to
like go through the newspaper and just
see different perspectives even and now
we just look at the score and we go it's
bad it's a good movie Bad movie yeah and
something we did everything as Americans
I think because even there used to be a
whole
quick critique like
roll like a job like you're a film
critic you were like a food critic right
like you spent hella time studying it
creating like and then there used to
your opinions to mean something like but
now it doesn't [__] matter because
now it's like millions of people with
[__] taste yep yeah dude we just want to
and I do this too by the way like if I
see a movie like being reviewed on some
website I just scroll all the way down
to see what the score is before I even
decide if I want to read part of your
culture now for how you check yeah it's
also weird too because I didn't think
about that about how like certain films
could lose or gain distribution based on
their Rotten Tomatoes score I don't know
I didn't think about that it's just so
popular like it became the new standard
like my dad used to open up the
newspaper and he would look at the
reviews of like you know oh Roger Ebert
and Cisco the reviews are in yeah and we
would decide what movie we're gonna see
right yeah and usually we're already
pretty hyped up remember they even had a
show they were like the top five movies
of the weekend or whatever watch that
[__] but like let's go neighbor well
that's what probably has a what's blood
sweats Rotten Tomatoes score that's
probably wrong dude it's probably 30 I
like how blood Sports should be the best
movie ever you know what I mean like
that that's a movie where like if you
didn't know what it was you might have
missed it if you just looked at the
score look I love Bloodsport me too I
think it's [__] way better than 46
see it's wrong they got love story you
played rotten it's under 60. action but
74 audience score but but Van Damme kind
of sucks in these movies he's not that
good he's like really weird you can make
the argument of like dude he kind of
wrote dude he's a great actor he should
have got Oscar for this scene
that was that was dope you know what I
mean I was a Believer I think he got
nominated but dude yesterday we were
hanging out with with with
um
um [__] dietrichs and he was
like ashamed of his acting I'm like
you're way better than [__] Clan Van
Damme
I don't even know D Tristan do the
splits and that movie where he was
acting got a six percent so yeah I just
don't understand he made a movie for men
but he's always got to be wearing tight
silky underwear and he's bent over he
knows what men want remember he shows
his butt Bart Diggs is better the Wizard
of Oz dude
Immaculate taste here's the thing you're
not gonna watch this dude
if you order a [__] Pizza Hut you're
gonna turn on Wizard of Oz or Bloodsport
exact amundo that's that's a good about
that's a really good take it's a good
take it's a good take it's a good take
but if my mom's around
I have to put on Wizard of Oz I can't
put on both words
[Music]